they called him machete seven dollars a
day for your wonderful roofing
get in 125 perceptive see which never
killed anyone before he kills in the bad
guys anywhere the most entertaining
movies hey Shetty's been with the most
entertaining movies to put together for
me I mean I've had the best time it's
cuz it's been such a long period of time
and I always knew he could from the
trailer to when we shot to even if we
did any reshoot with Danny to add some
extra bits in it seemed like it was
something I could always come back to
Rose I'm sad it's wrapping up we're
gonna have to do sequels Robert actually
told me about the character machete when
we were doing desperado so everybody
thinks it came from the trailer but
actually the trailer came from the story
Robert told he just said hey you know I
really like you for this character and
it was basically the story of Marchetti
I wrote it put it on a shelf registered
head and all that and then when it came
time to do grindhouse you know and
Rodriguez saw back
they are back to this Quinn and I talked
about doing faced trailers and on I know
what I'm gonna do a trailer for it's a
movie that I've already got in my head I
can write the trailer in two seconds
because I already know what the movie is
and and I kind of wrote it different for
the trailer a storyline that would fit
into a trailer he was given an offer he
couldn't refuse so then what happened
after the movie came out is people gave
that the highest marks of anything
people love that trailer that's what
opened the movie they had never seen
damn exploitation before where the
actual mexican superhero and she's never
seen it so it felt very new and very
different and Danny's attitude and Andy
bean in the headline position people
just ate it up when we decided to
finally make it after a few years of
everywhere I'd go more than sin city two
people would say are you going to make
machete and I would lie saying oh of
course we were sure we are they would
get very excited so I thought okay we'll
have to make it and stranger is I want
to keep everything from that original
trailer in this movie so years later
we're going to shoot new material that
fits into it so I have to work backwards
and write backwards how does he end up
in the waterfall with the two beautiful
women and figure out a scene and put a
twist on it so that it surprises the
audience who's so familiar with that
first trailer I kept asking him can we
shoot that scene again Robert a robber
get what you know how we already did it
we got it years ago I love the character
much ethic because he's really just a
hard-working guy ends up a superhero but
doesn't have to wear tights or spandex
no i mean so it is it is the perfect
Danny Trejo Viet he starts in Mexico
he's already the best mexican federal
agent in mexico because of the situation
down there with a
cartels and that he's an uncorruptible
which makes him a huge target and his
family's wiped out he's pretty much
burned up left 4 dead escapes to the US
working as a day laborer and encounters
a lot of the same corruption from both
sides of the border working together and
kind of cannot stop being the badass cop
federally he goes and investigates it
figures out what's really happening and
brings it all down he becomes as very
iconic character that people have been
waiting for to make sense out of this
situation he goes from x Conda icon the
corruption so deep coming from both
sides and no one is willing to tackle
that ever and that's what the problem is
and that's why you have you have to
create a superhero to come in and say
well this guy could at least make some
sense out of its make people more aware
what's going on that's him gif be a dl
rule up in
still doing out of how i started i
started in me you know mariachi out of
my apartment and the studio bought it I
realized well I don't have to relocate
over there I can use the resources I
have here in my hometown be closer to my
family and it turned out to be a very
smart move because you end up coming up
with new ways of doing things because
you're not near the system that does
things very traditionally when you're
when you're moving away George Lucas
told me that he goes you're going to
come up with things you wouldn't
normally come up with because when I
lived outside of Hollywood in Marin
County I came up with the idea of
digital studio the avid pro tools you
know he came up with all these different
things because you do what makes sense
creatively and not well what does
everyone else doing ok I'll do it their
way you do the way that really makes no
sense and then you end up coming up with
you know something like how to do sin
city or doing 3d with their no HD
cameras before anybody was doing that so
really isn't as antagonistic way
everything that happens in Hollywood
happens I just find a more productive a
lot more productive when I'm kind of out
on a ranch somewhere making a movie far
far far away but they soon realize
coming after us
they just with the wrong mexican
i mean we have a lot of effects in it
but it's very much than some of the
realistic movies where you don't know
their effect shops there enhancements
that you would normally think our affect
jobs just to make everything look real
yet over-the-top enough big huge yeah
they're invisible effects thank you
Trejo I know sir crew shirt as a crew
shirt if you're gonna hire machete to
chill the bad guy you better make damn
sure the bad guy is
machete actually I write children's
books my spirit
you